well the last two starts have not been
good for jf six innings combined 11
earned and four home runs allowed so
trying to change that here today and the
o2 pitch
and the strikeout the first of the
afternoon paints the inside corner
he's been throwing the ball much better
sonny gray has overall one game over 500
and he is 82 and 69 in his major league
career today making start number 211.
o'neal swings and grounds it through the
hole and a very small hole with three on
the left side of the infield that went
in between india and the shortstop last
night arenado hit a two-run homer to put
the cardinals over the top and that came
with two outs and a 2-0
arenado with number 31
and a deep left
back-to-back days with two-run blasts
and it's two-nothing
st louis
he's now five for 10 against sunny gray
home run number 31
and he's four shy of the century mark
and runs patted in up to 96.
and a swing and a miss as vato strikes
out number two
this afternoon for half
and a ground ball right to nolan aronado
good start for half six up six down the
young vader kisner coming up it's two
nothing
short left center field out goes india
in comes the center fielder it's the
shields calling off both india and the
left fielder aristidis aquino drop step
kick and pitch the 2-2 swing and a miss
struck him out down on strikes andrew
kissner gray works a one two three
second and the one-two pitch to sonny
gray
we're close as he strikes out so j-hat
first time through the lineup no walks
no hits and has struck out three
india to left center
down
a turn at second cabrera holds
two out hit
for india another well deserved hit well
earned
so two outs and two on and a ground ball
that's hit to short
and a flip and a force head second base
no damage done
grey uses it all
and the payoff he strikes out so the
first swing
of this at bat for edmond he comes up
empty
cabrera
[Applause]
a one two three inning
since the homer gray has set down
there's a strikeout of
joey votto and number four
[Applause]
off the end of the bat taken there by
edmond
for scoreless put up so far for jay hep
oh boy
that's the worst
that's the worst of all times that makes
me more mad than anything on this planet
you got those the ball at you and you
get a swing i think mike shield has been
ejected
he cannot argue balls and strikes
and so the manager is going to go out
and talk it over with doug eddings the
crew chief
hopefully i'll be able to get his
money's worth now there's no way that
you can do anything but get out of the
way right there and
that's your swing
and yeah he did go technically
that is the most frustrating thing ever
as a hitter sometimes you just wish that
they would give you a break
look out here well i thought some but we
were told somebody was just ejected
and apparently it was not mike schilt
because he's still sitting in the dugout
so arenado having words quickly with the
first base umpire
on the backhand
gray has retired 10 in a row
since oronato's first ending homer
and he made the play gray gets the k his
third strikeout of the afternoon
on the backhand
13 in a row
set down by 74. luis garcia called to
the pen 23 consecutive scoreless innings
the 2-2
swung on and missed
lovato flips the bet flips the helmet
strands a runner garcia continues his
mastery coming out of the st louis pen
man has this guy been good
[Music]
now the pitch and tommy hits this one up
the middle of the infield on through
into center of base hit
that wasn't scorched edmond with a wide
turn goes back
as the shields hurried his throw into
the shortstop suarez
low for ball four two on with one out
for tyler o'neill
struck him out fastball right down the
middle
arenado
to center to shields
and gray glides out of the jam
pin point
heater on the inside edge carlson down
looking
now there aren't too many pitchers in
baseball that have the ability to throw
this pitch the way that sonny gray does
i remember greg maddox used to live on
this pitch a little front door fastball
struck him out six case for gray a
perfect seventh inning and outstanding
outing
from sonny griggs
the shields turns out a hundred to the
gap
he can fly he shoots up to second
it'll shut it down there
a lead off double
by delino de shields
[Applause]
into right
down the line
and it's caught by dylan carlson
reaching into the stands
what a play by dylan to get underneath
it
reaching in and making the catch
here it comes he got him and the
strikeout dreadful digits
and it's still a two-nothing saint louis
lead
giovanni gallegos
during this home stand has not allowed a
base runner through three outings four
and two thirds on this home stand one
ball two strikes on castellanos
and he got him a strikeout to begin the
night
[Applause]
mustaches to the gap
all the way to the wall
mustaches rumbles up to second base a
double and there's still a heartbeat the
tying run bats for the reds
the o2
the strikeout for giovanni gallegos the
cardinals hold on it's a shutout two
nothing in the final and they take two
of three
what a weekend series here in st louis
after dropping the game on
friday night the cardinals
take two of three against the reds and
certainly still in the hunt for the wild
card